[Musique]
nous avons constaté que les Français
souhaitaient qu'il y ait un
renouvellement du personnel politique
dans les différentes assemblées
nationales que ce soit l'Assemblée
nationale ou le Sénat et donc l'idée
c'était effectivement que qu'il y ait un
nouvel élan démocratique au sein de la
chambre haute du parlement pour
représenter ces
aspirations nouvelles du peuple français
à travers leur grand leurs grands
électeurs
nous nous opposons aux zones à faible
émission ces zones qui sont des zones
discriminatoires et qui vont impacter
notamment les départements de grandes
couronnes
nous nous opposons également à
l'implantation d'éoliennes et en cela la
8e la 9e et la dixième circonscription
sont concernés par le schéma régional
éolien d'implantation d'éoliennes donc
nous nous opposons à cela depuis très
longtemps au-delà de ça nous souhaitons
également protéger les élus puisque nous
avons vu les gens j'en parlerai juste
après mais nous avons vu à l'occasion
des émeutes du mois de juin juillet
dernier que les élus étaient de plus en
plus agressés nous souhaitons les
protéger en sanctionnant sévèrement les
auteurs d'agression
[Musique]
nous vivons une période très trouble
pour notre pays pour notre République
les émeutes qui ont eu lieu fin juin
début juillet ont démontré que nos
services publics nos institutions et nos
élus étaient attaqués étaient pris pour
cible c'est la République c'est la
France qui a été qui a été attaqué et je
pense qu'à l'occasion de ces élections
sénatoriales les grands électeurs ont
l'opportunité d'envoyer un message
[Musique]
tout simplement pour les mêmes raisons
qu'il y a 6 ans je me suis pris il y a 6
ans dans avec pour objectif de servir
mon pays et d'être utile à mon pays en
particulier dans les domaines de
compétences dans des domaines dans
lesquels je suis compétent pardon
excusez-moi et je pense qu'il y a encore
beaucoup de travail à faire sur ces
sujets là et que nous avons depuis 6 ans
commencé et plus que ça à réparer la
France et qui encore beaucoup de travail
à faire et que je pense encore être
utile pour mon pays pendant 6 ans
j'ai la chance de partir d'un bilan
d'abord à l'inverse je pense de tous les
autres candidats qui ne peuvent pas être
bilan puisqu'ils représentent pas la
majorité présidentielle nous avons un
bilan que moi j'estime fort qui n'est
pas parfait les bilans aucun bilan n'est
parfait mais nous avons des grandes
forces donc des grands thèmes ça va être
bien sûr pour moi la santé le droit le
travail la solidarité transformée tout
ce qui assistana dans notre pays en
solidarité qui me singing me paraît un
élément très très important retrouver
une économie stable et solide un déficit
qui va baisser sont les grandes lignes
j'avais dit bien sûr la santé j'en ai
pas parlé mais la santé qui est un
élément très très important avec les
grandes difficultés que nous allons
vivre pendant plusieurs années
[Musique]
alors en quelques mots il y aurait le
RSA toute la réflexion comporte sur le
RSA et sur l'assurance chômage toute
cette logique de solidarité non plus
d'assistanats donc aider les personnes
non pas à s'installer dans le chômage
mais en sortir quelle que soit leur
difficulté aller vers eux pour les
sortir du chômage quoi qu'il arrive ça
c'est essentiel pour nous dans une
logique de solidarité et puis le
deuxième sujet je vais en prendre un
deuxième quand même malgré tout c'est
vraiment la santé parce que ceux qui n'a
pas été fait en 2005 ceux qui n'a pas
été fait en 2010 nous l'avons fait en
2018 mais c'était déjà tellement tard
que pendant 20 ans il y aura beaucoup de
difficultés de santé en France et nous
devons accompagner ce travail en
travaillant sur le temps médical qui est
vraiment un sujet que je porte depuis 6
ans maintenant et sur lequel nous
travaillons avec ce gouvernement depuis
6 ans mais malheureusement ça aurait dû
être fait il y a 20 ans
[Musique]
contactez la liste n'a pas répondu à nos
sollicitations
[Musique]
debout la France que je représente est
un parti d'opposition actuellement on
est opposé à la politique d'Emmanuel
Macron on est également un parti
gaulliste et on a estimé qu'il y avait
pas vraiment cette notion de gaulliste
d'opposition qui était représenté au
Sénat
en particulier les républicains qui pour
nous aurait dû jouer ce rôle
sont un petit peu frileux on va dire
alors comme dans les Yvelines monsieur
l'archet et candidat les républicains
j'ai proposé de me présenter contre lui
pour montrer un petit peu l'exemple
l'État a beaucoup investi dans certains
quartiers défavorisés de certaines zones
et puis dans les grandes villes on le
voit en termes de transport par exemple
et de moyens de police et on trouve que
la ruralité les campagnes les petites
communes sont abandonnées il n'y a plus
de services publics les services de
proximité disparaissent les médecins ne
s'y installent plus et les maires et les
conseillers municipaux sont complètement
abandonnés voilà donc on estime que il
faut défendre nos territoires défendre
les petites communes défendre la
ruralité et puis aider les maires à ce
que leur commune et leur ville permettre
un bon niveau de vie et sous très
agréable
[Musique]
écoutez je vais vous parler des Yvelines
nous sommes dans les Yvelines
les Yvelines représentent un petit peu
tout le tout ce qu'on peut trouver en
France et je crois que les Yvelines
permettraient de mettre en exemple une
façon de vivre qui nous plaît une façon
de vivre harmonieuse ou on peut décider
d'habiter soit à la campagne soit en
ville mais en tout cas en toute
tranquillité
[Musique]
je me présente aux élections
sénatoriales du de septembre 2023 parce
que je pense qu'il y a énormément de
travail à faire pour améliorer des
relations notamment les relations entre
l'État et les collectivités et
particulièrement les communes
le premier c'est la volonté de s'engager
je crois qu'en ce moment les seuls qui
traduisent leur volonté de s'engager de
façon forte et professionnelle ce sont
les parties extrémistes les parties de
la gauche extrême et les parties de la
droite extrême il ne faut pas leur
laisser la place c'est notre motivation
première à tous donc pour cela il faut
s'engager il faut travailler il faut
être présent et le dire à nos
concitoyens et le dire à tous les élus
le deuxième c'est de travailler sur les
le lien à perfectionner entre les
directives de l'État et leur application
de ces directives au sein des communes
ça c'est un chantier très important que
ce soit le logement social que ce soit
les transports que ce soit l'éducation
que ce soit la transition énergétique on
sent que les directives vont dans le bon
sens leur application au niveau des
communes est difficile
[Musique]
nous vivons un moment politique en
France où nous avons plus que jamais
besoin d'une politique constructive et
saine les parties traditionnelles sont
en cours de réorganisation des parties
républicains sont en réorganisation au
niveau national le Parti socialiste est
en cours de reconstruction complète le
parti horizon offre une perspective de
travail qui est en ce moment la
meilleure selon nous pour construire la
particularité
l'organisation nationale d'horizon
travaille directement avec les mers
directement avec les collectivités
locales et nous avons l'impression qu'en
ce moment c'est la meilleure façon de
gagner du temps et d'être plus efficace
c'est la démarche dans laquelle nous
nous inscrivons
[Musique]
avec l'équipe qui m'accompagne
représentée les Yvelines représenter les
258 communes des Yvelines c'est être
utile à mon pays m'engager m'engager
pour mon pays et je dois dire
être une des deux chambres du Parlement
en ces temps d'incertitude notamment
avec l'absence de majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale nous donne une responsabilité
particulière et je pense que j'ai une
responsabilité avec pardonnez-moi
d'expérience qui est la mienne de la
transmettre à l'équipe et de la mettre
au service de mon pays
aux affaires économiques Sophie prima
qui représente tous les grands sujets
d'aujourd'hui la crise énergétique mais
aussi les difficultés que rencontre les
communes en matière d'urbanisme et puis
Michel Laugier qui est très attentif
dans les Yvelines au dossier de la ligne
18 au dossier du plateau de Saclay
Martha Sidrac dans l'arrondissement de
Saint-Germain avec son engagement sur la
transition écologique sur l'économie
circulaire et puis toi de Bora qui a été
la révélation depuis 3 ans sur les
questions scolaires et de harcèlement
[Musique]
ça dépendra de la confiance que nous
ferons les élus et les délégués
sénatoriaux notre objectif n'est pas un
objectif strictement partisan nous
sommes vous le voyez une liste de
rassemblement assez large
notre approche est ensemble pour les
Yvelines donc une équipe pour les
Yvelines
[Musique]
c'est parce que j'ai été mère une petite
commune rurale dans le nord-yvelines et
je suis aujourd'hui conseillère
régionale je pense connaître réellement
les préoccupations aujourd'hui que
rencontrent les collectivités dans les
Yvelines
je mène d'ailleurs une liste union de la
gauche et des écologistes et mon
programme c'est de pouvoir préparer et
accompagner les collectivités pour et
bien préparer la transition préparer la
résilience de nos territoires s'assurer
que nos habitants puissent à la fois
pouvoir continuer à bénéficier d'un
cadre de vie agréable d'un emploi et de
pouvoir se loger dignement en fait c'est
ce que en règle générale et les aigus
locaux font au sein de leur territoire
et donc il y a un pilier vraiment
environnemental un pilier de justice
sociale et un également un pilier
démocratique aujourd'hui notre notre
pays fonctionne un coup de 49,3 et je
crois que la chambre des territoires le
Sénat doit aujourd'hui porter au
contraire la défense d'une vraie
démocratie locale
[Musique]
je crois qu'il y a aujourd'hui une
urgence une urgence climatique une
urgence sociale et je crois que
l'ensemble des collectivités
territoriales en fait plutôt que
d'essayer aujourd'hui de les regrouper
de leur couper leur capacité d'agir je
crois qu'aujourd'hui au contraire parce
que nous sommes dans ce temps d'urgence
il faut faire confiance à nos élus
locaux il faut absolument s'assurer que
demain lorsqu'il parle à leurs habitants
et puis se véhiculer une image positif
de l'État mais pour ça il faut leur
donner les moyens d'agir les moyens de
pouvoir
rénover les bâtiments publics de pouvoir
faire des économies sur sur les charges
les fluides sur sur les charges
énergétiques et donc surtout leur donner
la capacité de pouvoir répondre aux
besoins et aux préoccupations pardon de
leur de leur habitant
[Musique]
nous présentons cette liste parce que
nous souhaitons poursuivre la dynamique
qui a été celle de la nups pendant les
élections présidentielles c'est-à-dire
offrir la possibilité aux électeurs
électrices de voter pour le programme de
la nupes et donc c'est en continuité
avec cette dynamique là que nous
présentons une liste dans chaque
département en France
c'est un programme de rupture avec
l'ordre établi par les macronistes ces
dernières années la fin de la
dégradation des services publics
labolition de la réforme des retraites
présentées par le gouvernement il y a
quelques mois et puis le passage à une
sixième république donc c'est le même
programme que nous portons aux élections
législatives parce que et bien c'est
juste une autre chambre de notre
Parlement
l'intérêt d'avoir des sénateurs et
sénatrices insoumis vous imaginez il est
énorme au Sénat on basculerait justement
la façon dont se font les choses on
ramènerait le peuple dans le Sénat qui
aujourd'hui est une chambre qui
malheureusement de par sa composition
échappe légèrement largement pardon au
pouvoir de contrôle citoyen c'est à dire
que c'est très peu médiatisé on ne voit
pas ce qui se passe à l'intérieur les
élus insoumis changeront ça nous avons
cette capacité à créer le lien entre le
mouvement social les personnes
organisées les électeurs et ce qui se
passe à l'intérieur des Chambres du
Parlement
[Musique]